[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCHANER: Good morning.
I've been given the honor
of introducing our speaker.
My name is Simon Schaner,
and I'm a PhD candidate
in the Department of Economics.
Earlier this morning,
several of us students
were privileged to show Mr.
Gates examples of our research.
Mine focuses on the use of
malaria diagnostic tests
and anti malarials among
low-income households
in Africa.
Public health issues
such as malaria
are among the many problems
tackled by the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation in a quest
to help all people lead
healthy and productive lives.
At MIT, we share the
foundation's ambition
to confront big problems
with big solutions,
as we pursue our mission to
serve the nation and the world.
Mr. Gates has long been a
friend to the Institute,
and his work toward the
betterment of humankind
continues to inspire us.
We are honored that he
was chosen to visit us
as part of his college tour.
Please welcome Bill Gates.
[APPLAUSE]
GATES: Thank you.
Thank you.
Well it's great to be here.
When I dropped out of college,
I promised my dad I'd go back,
and so I'm doing it a
day at a time to work off
that debt that I've got.
This is the first
college set of visits
I've done since switching to
work full time for the Gates
Foundation.
And it's a little bit
different than the kind
of talks I gave when
I was coming out
focused on software,
focused on Microsoft.
I'll talk a bit about
technology and how
it's an enabling
factor, but mostly, I
want to talk about a
question that fascinates me
and that is are the
brightest minds working
on the most important problems?
And to the degree
that they're not,
how could we increase
that, which I think
would make a huge difference.
Now this is a question
that we'd like
to be as precise
as possible, but I
think it'll be tough to
be too numeric on it.
After all, if we
think about what do we
mean by the brightest minds?
You could have a range
of definitions of that,
but I think any
definition would include
the people who get to attend
the world's top 20 universities.
And so everyone here would
fit into that category.
Also, if we take a phrase
like important problems,
I think there would
be a different lists
that people would come up with.
I think there's some things
that would be in common.
The problems in poor countries,
the health problems, sanitation
problems, governance
problems, inability
to do savings, get loans,
all of those problems that
make life so much more difficult
for the bottom 2 billion,
versus particularly,
the richest 1 billion
would belong on that list.
And there'd be five or
six really big things
that we haven't put
enough attention into that
would make a huge difference.
We'd also have in the
list, some problems that
are more global in nature.
For example, the
problem of education.
It's not something that even
the world's richest country,
the United States,
has managed to improve
and make equitable and
make available to everybody
who should want it.
Or we'd have the
problem of energy,
where getting energy to
be lower and lower cost
is very important for
everybody, and now we
have a new constraint
that we have
to do that in a
way that eliminates
the environmental negative
effects, including that CO2
emission.
You might have on the
list the difficulty
of feeding the world,
where you don't
have much more acreage you can
put under cultivation, and yet
both the population
increase, a factor of 1.5,
and the dietary change you
get as people get richer
mean that we're going to
have to have about three
times the agricultural
output and the only trick
that we have for that is
increased productivity.
And so a huge
challenge, also one
with significant
environmental constraints.
So those are the kinds of things
I think about when I think
about the important problems.
And for many of these problems,
the amount of work that's
been done on very
essential questions,
it always stuns me
how few bright minds
have worked on those things.
How little effort and
energy and investigation
there is on those
things, and it makes
me wonder how we
might change that.
How we might make these
things more exciting.
I was thinking about this.
About three weeks ago, I
was with some friends just
goofing around on the weekend,
and they had a couple topics
that their incredible minds
had really focused on,
and were thinking in
this rich, deep way,
where they knew the history,
they knew the strategies,
they know the outputs.
The two topics were
first, NCAA March Madness
and what was going to
happen in basketball.
I don't remember
anyone mentioning
them MIT team in those
discussions, but that's okay.
And they really had
studied these problems.
They had those
brackets and they were
talking about which was going to
be best and a wonderful debate
about those topics.
And the second thing was
discussing of investments.
Who had pick good stocks, what
had happened in the mortgage
market, what was going to happen
with the investment banks,
what kind of derivatives were
there, and did various people
understand what you
might choose to do
in investing in those things.
And all that IQ,
including lots of IQ
that goes off to Wall Street
and just works on those topics
is there full time thing.
So we have lots of talent
that could be shifted,
at least to some degree,
from sports, entertainment,
investing, even in the
areas of innovation,
a great science that's it's
done here and other places.
A lot of that focuses on
the needs of the rich.
There's a lot of great
work on baldness drugs.
Now, I'm not talking
about a complete shift,
because I still want to have
some movies, I like movies,
and I certainly know people
that would be easier to look at
if they'd use the baldness drug.
But how could we have
a shift of, both people
who work on these issues
on a full time basis,
and perhaps even more
importantly, people
who although it's not
their full time focus,
that they're engaged
in these things.
They picked one or two, and
their time, their donation,
their political voice is
involved in these things.
I think if you look at the trend
over the last 15 years or so,
there has been an increase,
and places like MIT
have been very good in
taking leadership on this.
If you look at the visibility
of issues like malaria and AIDS,
it is much higher today
than any time in the past.
And that is resulting in
more government donations,
more scientists working
on those things.
Still, if you take malaria,
it's a pretty small set.
There's less than 100
scientists who work
on the key problems of malaria.
Kills a million children a year,
should it have more than that,
maybe so.
So we've seen a change.
My generation was not
that aware of poverty
and what was going on.
I don't know whether
it was the Cold War
or what the distraction was, but
it was not as visible, not as
clear as it starting to be.
Now I see this
shift in many ways.
I see it in terms of what the
students here are going into,
I have a project up in Seattle,
which is about using software
to model diseases.
And a MIT graduate,
[INAUDIBLE] is working on that.
And she could make 10
times as much money
working on something else, but
this idea of modeling malaria,
and other diseases, and
testing out the tactics
and using actually this
Monte Carlo simulation, which
is a technique from
physics applying it
to that in this very rich way.
Now, that problem
has drawn her in,
and we've got this team of
amazing people doing that.
We have some exemplars.
People like Paul
Farmer, who people
aspire to do the kind of work
that he does, and it's not just
the global issues, also on
education and Teach for America
is a new phenomena.
Here at MIT, there were 96
people in the graduating class
who applied for
Teach for America,
and that's 7.5% of the class,
and that's pretty amazing,
because every one
of those kids would
have had other opportunities
that would have been far more
renumeration.
So there is this
increased visibility.
I myself, did not go through
some rational process
of picking what I
wanted to work on
based on either economics or
it ranking high on some list
I wrote down great problems.
I fell into what I ended up
doing as my full time career.
I was 13, there was computer,
it confused the teachers,
it was fun to figure
it out, and that
became my fanatical
involvement, was thinking,
how could software improve?
How could it be better?
Trying to meet people
who had done more
and getting them to
critique what I'd done.
And then eventually, starting
a company around that idea.
And I feel good that you can
say through happenstance,
that work actually led
to a broad industry,
personal computing,
internet, software, that
has been incredibly empowering.
Has had, both in a
direct sense, but also
as a tool to be used for
these other problems,
it has been fantastic.
And so I don't look back
on that with any regret.
It what it did work out, but I
didn't know what was going on
in the world I was in my 40s.
Before in terms of
my travels, I started
really having an
awareness of how
tough health conditions were.
And I remember in particular
reading an article
about disease in poor
countries and seeing
there was a disease I've never
heard of called rotavirus that
was killing a million kids--
half a million kids a year--
and thinking, well,
boy, there must be a lot
of scientists working on that.
One fact, at that time,
there are about 10 scientists
working on that.
Not well-funded, and
just an obvious thing.
And so I thought, wow, the
world is not that rational.
It is not these things.
And in a way, that was good
news for me, personally,
it meant there were
some very clear things
that as I was taking
the Microsoft resources
and giving them back to society
and trying to have impact,
there were some low hanging
fruit that hadn't been picked.
I wasn't going to be--
if the world was rational--
my marginal dollars would
have far less utility
than if there were these things
that really had been missed.
But I want to do is take
two problems, including
that one of childhood deaths,
and talk about what's going on,
and some of the things that
need more bright minds,
and given a sense of the very
deep need on many of these,
and yet the great opportunity.
The chance of success.
I think if you took and tried
to give the world a report
card, one of the things you'd
have very strongly, even if you
only pick 10 measures, would be
the number of childhood deaths.
Some have there's an
effort now that we've
funded called the Millennium
Development Goals,
so they're trying to benchmark
where different countries are
in the progress, and set
fairly ambitious goals
for improving metrics.
And one of those
is this under five
childhood death number,
and the milestone
for those goals
as 2015, and we'll
make pretty good progress.
We want to achieve
them all, but it
has had a very positive effect.
So this is a very
interesting metric,
and I actually have one chart.
I'm only going to
show you one, but it's
my favorite chart in
the world, and that's
one that shows the
progress over time
in reducing these
childhood deaths.
If you go back to 1960,
over 20 million children
died that year.
If you come up to
the last year, which
was the most recent
measurement we have on this,
it was under 9 million children.
And there's about a 40% increase
in the size of the birth
cohort, so the actual
rate reduction you've got
is actually even better
than the factor of two
you see here in the
absolute number.
And so you might say,
how did that happen?
What is it?
Is it cancer drugs?
What kind of science did it?
And the answer is
although some of it
is just nutrition and income
levels, the general advance
of GDP per person and the
living conditions you're under.
By far, most of
that is vaccines.
Measles vaccine alone is over
a million of that reduction.
Smallpox vaccine
that led actually
to the first
eradication of a disease
altogether is a huge
part of this reduction.
Well over a million
death reduction
per year because of that.
And so vaccines,
which get less than 1%
of the focus on medical
spending, goes into that area.
They are responsible for
a really incredible amount
of health benefit.
Even in rich countries it's
a underappreciated element
of why things work.
And they're very cheap.
The manufacturing
cost comes down
over time to most a few
dollars you can deliver them.
As a group, you don't need
trained medical personnel
to do it.
And even in a country like
Somalia, where you essentially,
have no government, we have
quite high vaccination rates.
Actually much better than
we have in northern Nigeria,
northern India, where you have
a dysfunctional vaccination
system that's only getting to
30% in some of those areas.
So it's a huge problem we have
to fix, while at the same time,
we add in these new vaccines.
When you think about the
inequities of the child
to death--
I always think about how
is the way you can state
that that is the most clear?
One that I think is
interesting is to say,
other people who are born
the same year you were,
your birth cohort, how old were
you before 20% of you had died?
And in a rich country
in the United States,
you'd get past age 60
before 20% had died.
In a poor country,
the poorest, you
wouldn't get past age
four before 20% had died.
So you had a very
dramatic difference.
The thing that was mind blowing
when I found out about this
is the effect that
improved health
has on population growth.
The first thing
our foundation did
actually was invest in
reproductive health,
because we said, okay,
whatever the problems you're
interested in, not having too
many more people, whether it's
jobs, education, food,
environment, to not have sort
of Malthusian growth levels
like 3%, 4%, 5% a year,
which we fortunately, only
have in a few places now,
that is a primary problem.
And I wasn't sure how to think
about health interventions,
because are you schizophrenic?
Do you want more
people or less people,
and wouldn't that be
the first class effect?
Well, the answer is no.
Paradoxically, the
biggest intervention
that reduces the family size
that people want to have
is improving Childhood Health.
There's some others like
female literacy and things
that can be done.
Hans Rosling, who's
from Karolinska,
has a presentation on the web.
A Ted presentation, a number
of others, where he really
articulates there's only
two kinds of countries,
there's high population growth
countries with terrible health,
and there's low population
growth countries
with reasonable
health, and there's
no in between because
this effect is
so powerful that as you
improve Childhood Health,
parents who are trying to have a
few kids survive into adulthood
choose not to have as
large a family size.
So what you get is as soon as
you start to improve health,
all these other things
become tractable,
and you have many countries
that we used to think of as poor
and received aid-- even South
Korea 30 years ago got aid--
now, it's quite a
generous aid donor.
So it's a complete
turnaround from recipient
to giving within
a 40-year period,
but it's true of China,
Brazil, lots of countries.
So now we're down to
what Paul Collier calls
the bottom billion, maybe
a billion and a half or so
that are in this poverty
trap that we still
need to better on.
And the good news is that
despite the complexities
and difficulties
of these things,
something like vaccinations
can be delivered anywhere.
So inventing those,
getting them to be cheap,
getting them out, getting a
slightly better distribution
system will allow us to go from
that slightly under 9 million
that we're at today, down to
5 million down to 2.5 million,
and it has this
huge, huge effect.
The other problem I want to
take as an illustrative example
is education.
And education economists
of all the things
that's known for sure,
investing in education,
primary, secondary,
college level,
doing that in quality
way is the thing
that really allows a country to
improve its standard of living.
So both that at macro level, but
also at the individual level.
We all know from our
personal experience
that education is what makes
our life interesting, gives us
opportunity, and
so we should want
it to be broadly available.
If you look-- and I was
absolutely blown away
at the statistics, I had no
idea of how poorly the education
system in the US is working.
Over 30% of kids drop
out of high school.
If you're a minority, over
50% drop out of high school.
Even the ones who
complete, many of them
have had a really,
really poor education.
And so they sign up
for college, they
get into a remedial math
class, and half of those kids
never get any degree.
So they've got loans
they're paying off,
they've got this
negative experience,
they put time into it, and it
hasn't worked for them at all.
And so this education
system is quite poor,
and it's been covered up,
hasn't been that visible.
What we have now is a trend
that because of the way
state budgets are allocated,
a great education is going
to be more and more
out of reach, that is,
the tuition is more expensive.
And so we literally will have a
situation where less people are
getting college
educations unless we
do something fairly dramatic
to improve the efficiency.
Make some type of breakthrough.
So I'd say there's two things
that are very important.
One is to take the
quality of teaching,
and this is particularly
in K through 12,
and find out what the
best practices are,
and how to spread
those best practices.
And it blows my
mind how little work
has been done on
that to identify, now
that we know some teachers
are wildly better than most
teachers, you make over two
years of progress in math
if you get a top
quartile teacher,
and you make zero
years of progress
if you get a bottom
quartile teacher.
So what's going on?
Is it seniority?
We know it's not.
Is it having a PhD in math?
Actually, we know
it's not that either.
That has a very
little affect on it,
although people
are focused on it.
There's huge differences of how
the kids are being drawn in,
and yet we don't study that.
We don't invest in
spreading it around.
We don't measure teachers,
give them feedback,
it's a system, where there's
a huge opportunity to improve,
so that's important.
And the other thing I
think is using technology.
And here's a case where
MIT has absolutely
been at the forefront.
OpenCourseWare,
there's great numbers
in terms of how much it's being
used by millions of people.
I'm a super happy user.
I retook physics
with Walter Lewin,
I took Professor Sataway's
course and loved that.
I recommended it to everybody.
Eric Lander, biology, refresher
on differential equations,
actually of the 33 that they
have videos, I've taken 11.
And I just last night
spotted two new ones
that I need to take, so just
for me, it's a good thing.
But this is just the beginning.
And MIT did spark a lot of
people to do similar things,
but the percentage of
people using these things
and the difficulty
of finding something
and testing their knowledge.
Really bringing the best of
video, the best professors
in the world, have
interactive experiments,
interactive ways of testing your
knowledge, even accreditation.
Have a way that if you have
gathered this knowledge instead
of that all coming
bundled with a degree
where you had to be somewhere
for four years, fairly
expensive, say, quarter million.
Actually have the
accreditation piece
be separated out, so
you can have innovation,
in terms of how people
acquire the knowledge,
and separate it from
place based learning.
Now the exact path
to this is not clear.
There's some schools
like Rocketship,
who even at the middle school
level, are using online courses
and mixing that in
with live teaching.
It's an area that
needs to be tried,
and you have to keep
the kids motivated,
you have to help when they
get confused, some of that
will be face-to-face, but
there's online innovation
there too.
Right now, it's all
pretty fragmented.
Different universities
doing different courses.
It's kind of hard
to find things.
Academic growth has a
little bit of an aggregation
there, but that this can
improve very substantially.
I was talking with Victor
Xu about how we take speech
recognition and bring that in.
We were talking about making it
more modular if you just want
to learn different concepts.
So we are just scratching
the surface, and the need
to take this and
have teachers be
able to learn how to teach
better, to assign kids who
are ahead, to assign
kids who are behind,
or to have self-motivated
people going
and use this and have it be
a worldwide resource that's
very clear who should
use what, that's
something that needs get done.
And again, it's what's
been done so far
has had very modest funding.
This is an area we need more
resources, more bright minds,
and certainly one that I want
to see how the foundation can
make a contribution to this.
So if you look at the
two issues, childhood
deaths, education, or if
you look at the other ones.
Savings, where the cell phone
can bring down the transaction
costs, sanitation or advanced
physics and chemistry
you really can do that
in a different way.
Energy may be the
toughest one of all,
but again, one where MIT is
marshalling its resources
to make a strong
contribution as it can.
These important
problems, there's
reasons to believe we
can't make progress,
but that rate of progress will
be somewhat proportional to how
we draw people in.
Draw them in full
time, draw them in part
time on these issues.
So it does leave this,
almost meta question
of how to get the
brightest people more
on to these big problems.
Why don't they work on them?
Well, the economic rewards
aren't totally in line
with these problems.
That's interesting, we can think
about what would change that.
The visibility, getting
the success stories out,
how can we do that?
My dream is that, say a few
years from now, I'll go off
and I'll have a weekend,
and instead of talking
about March Madness
and stock prices,
we'll have these brackets
about the best teaching
and which ideas have been
tried, team teaching, online,
and we'll be comparing
which has really come out
with the best outcomes.
And then we'll talk
about food and the best
seeds, the new agricultural
practices that are increasing
this productivity, and we'll
have that same excitement
and understanding that we
have about other topics.
I don't think that specifically
is going to be easy to achieve,
but it's kind of
the high bar of why
aren't these topics as
interesting, as engaging
as those other things.
And if we really
did that, yes, we
might delay the invention
of a new financial product
by a few years, we might even
delayed that baldness drugs
by a few years.
But if it helps on the
important problems,
I think it's a good thing.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Great.
Well, the rest of
time is for Q&A.
I think the way it's set
up, there's the two mics.
There's one here and one there.
And just go to the mics
and ask a question.
Just say your name and what
area you're studying in.
Give me a little bit of
context, that'd be great,
so go ahead here.
CHAN: Mike and I are actually
here to ask the same question.
My name is Grace Chan, and I'm
a member of a student initiative
here at MIT called
Leaders in Global Health
Transformations, or LIGHTs.
We're composed of undergraduate
students, graduates,
and business students
from across campus.
Now, as the world's
foremost supporter
of technological solutions
to global health,
you know better than
anyone that in order
to produce a new technology
that has a large global impact,
not only is there a need
for inventive scientists
and engineers to build
the technology, but also
a need for great entrepreneurs
to disseminate the technology
and build value.
A need for people who understand
delivery and operations
on the ground, and a need for
rigorous evaluation and systems
analysis.
Here at MIT, we have
the world's best minds
in all of these areas,
and many of these experts
are currently engaging
in various projects
in global health.
Results of a survey rewrite,
we recently distributed
through the provost's
office revealed
that over 40 MIT faculty are
engaged in some global health
research, and 17 student groups
have an interest in this area.
However, these efforts are
currently very isolated,
with little collaboration
between the different sectors.
We believe that if these
efforts are better coordinated,
MIT as a whole, would
be very well positioned
to play an important
role in solving poverty
in global health.
So our questions to
you are threefold.
First, would you be--
[LAUGHTER]
--would you be supportive of
a centralized administrative
led initiative, committed
to supporting global health
at MIT, much like the initiative
that already exists for energy.
Two, how do you think
this initiative might
be implemented?
And three, how would
the Gates Foundation
be interested in partnering
with such an initiative?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GATES: Well, I
definitely applaud
the work that's going on.
And I do think MIT is
an exemplar of this.
One of the things
we're trying to get
is the institutions in
the developing countries,
particularly in Africa and
India, more involved in this
and transfer some of the
expertise and skills,
so that they, where
the needs are,
actually are more
capable of doing
some of the elements,
including policy,
measurement, things
of that kind.
The idea of how
universities organize,
now, it's not a deep
expertise that I have,
and so the question of whether
there should be a minor
or some new thing that
pulls us together,
I think that's definitely
worth looking at.
I'd encourage you if you do it,
though, to not just take health
by itself.
I'd say broaden it to
international development,
because the issues of
agriculture, savings,
there's quite a few issues,
and I'd say the awareness
and MIT of the health
issues is ahead
of some of those other issues.
And yet, the kind of
expertise is equally
applicable to those things.
And once we improve
health, we still
want to work on those things.
Today, what we've done with MIT
is we take particular projects
like the measurement and
evaluation, and we fund that.
Bruce Walker does a lot
of the best work on AIDS,
and we fund a lot
of his activities.
Whether a particular
things should
be done at a single
university level here
or there's some other
missing thing, I'm not sure.
I did see a few
things today where
people are doing medical
instruments, where I said,
okay, we should make
sure that the needs.
What are they using, what are
the problems, what they're
using, what is the gap
there that we really
do a survey so people are
picking the right thing.
So that's a particular
one, but we'll
have a dialogue about whether a
minor an Institute makes sense,
and whether that's value
added or how that can help.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
GOLDBERG: Hi my name
is Michael Goldberg,
and I'm a postdoc in
the Cancer Center.
Really, I just want
to say thank you
for coming to speak
with us today.
And on behalf of MIT and
really everyone in the world,
thank you for the
work you've done,
you do, and will continue to do.
GATES: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MENCHACA: Hi.
My name is Alejandra Menchaca.
I work on energy
efficiency in buildings,
and my question has to do
with population growth.
In my field, we try to reduce,
or at least where I work on,
we're trying to
reduce demand in order
that we don't have to work
too hard on the supply side.
In terms of population,
it's a hard issue
to tell people whether to have
a certain number of kids or not,
but clearly, population
growth is clearly
a problem, in
terms of supplying,
as you mentioned earlier,
the food, and the energy,
and everything
staying sustainable.
Do you think we will ever get
to a point in which population
will be controlled in a
more legal way, or something
like that, or it's something
that will never be touched?
I know I wouldn't
like to be told,
you can't have more than
a certain number of kids,
but at the same time,
it is a problem.
So how do you see that issue?
GATES: Yeah, the miracle here.
If you go back to
1970, the estimates
were that world population
would reach about 20 billion,
and that's because people didn't
understand this effect of how
health would have an impact.
And so they lowered
it to 18 to 16 to 14,
and now the consensus
is about 9.2 billion
peak global population
in about 2050.
Now on a global basis,
that's probably okay,
and we won't do much.
Maybe we could get it
to be 8.5 or something,
the problem is that population
growth is exactly where we
have the least resources.
The least good government, the
least infrastructure, the least
education, the least
food capability, and all
of the increase from
the current 6.2 billion
that we're at today to that
around 9 billion plus or minus,
is going to come in poor
countries in urban cities.
That a lot of the births will
be in the rural areas, but net,
it's going to be in
these mega cities that
are somewhat dysfunctional.
And so our reproductive
health program
is able to substantially
lower birth rates
because there's
unmet demand that is,
if you just go out to
women and tell them,
okay, there's a shot They can
take that works for 90 days,
or there's an implant that
works for three years.
We're going to be able to bring
the price of those supplies
down very dramatically.
And it's an area that was
ridiculously not funded.
In fact, the US
government completely
pulled out of the UN population
group because of this issue
that some of these groups are
involved in voluntary abortion,
and so the US didn't
want to be connected
in any way with that piece.
Now, that rule, the so-called
Mexico City gag rule
was eliminated by
President Obama.
So for the first
time, the US is back
funding some of the
delivery activities.
But the innovation here,
there's a lot that can be done.
As you bring the price of these
things down, the injections,
the implants, as you get the
word out, the demand is there.
So it's all
completely voluntary.
Women want to have a
smaller family in all
of these high
population growth areas,
and so there's no need to
worry about coercive things.
In fact, back in the 60s,
the Club of Rome people
who were these doom
and gloom people
we're saying that we had to
have coercive techniques,
and they just didn't understand.
So you have a very
positive view of this.
People want to have
smaller families,
the advances are coming
that will make that easier.
It won't come soon enough
in a way, take Tanzania,
it's a population
of 42 million now.
Even with a modest birth
rate, it'll get to 90 million
because they have the
age structure as such,
you have all these
young people, that when
they go and have their
children, will all about double
the population.
One of the ironies in population
is that the rich countries
are shrinking.
The US is the only rich country
that has population growth.
Japan, Italy, Germany
are shrinking.
Mexico, even at their
middle income level,
is actually shrinking.
And yet, you think, oh, we
should have more immigration.
We should take all
these young people
and keep our age
structure reasonable,
but politically, that's
fairly difficult to do.
Even in India, this
is an amazing thing,
in the south of India in
Kerala there below, which
is the part of India with
really good health care,
it's subjectively the
best, they're actually
below replacement rate,
whereas, in the same country
you go up to Uttar Pradesh,
that's 3.5% growth year, so one
of the highest population
growth in the entire world.
The two highest
population growth areas
are actually northern
Nigeria, northern India,
which is also where you
don't have good vaccination.
And so in a way, it's
good news because you
do the interventions with
the reproductive health
and the vaccines and
the childhood care
all in the same places,
and it's very focused
where you go and do that work.
BRYAN: My name's Alan Bryan.
I am in the Health
Sciences and Technology.
I have a PhD in Bioinformatics.
I'm a medical student,
and so I'm now going
to work in medical informatics.
My question is single,
but with two applications.
You spoke of particularly
vaccines and an improving
education methods.
In both, there's a
two-part problem.
One, is how to find
what works better,
and the second is how to get
what works better out to people
who need it.
In both cases, which
do you find harder?
So for vaccines, is
it harder, and this
is based on your past experience
talking to people and then
their future projections.
Is it harder to do the
research to find the vaccine,
or to establish the cold chain
that gets it out to people.
And likewise, in
education reform,
is it harder to figure out
what best practices really
are that are
transferable and are not
innate to some organization,
or some teacher's
personal patterns of
action or something.
Or is it harder to talk through
the accreditation process,
and schools of education,
departments of education,
so forth, to get it
integrated into the system?
GATES: Yeah, that's
a very good question.
And the answer is different
for the two different domains.
In the case of vaccines,
we are science limited.
That is, an AIDS
vaccine is very tricky
and we're having to learn basic
things about molecular shape
space, immunology,
it is interesting,
but it's taking us a lot longer
because we haven't gotten lucky
on that one.
So that is science limited.
Malaria vaccine it's
criminal that we didn't
work on it, because probably
the science of the 80s or 90s
were good enough to
do a malaria vaccine.
They were not good enough
to know an AIDS vaccine.
Even if we'd been
working super hard,
we just don't have the
fundamental understanding.
Most of the diseases we work on,
the vaccines aren't that hard,
it's just there wasn't
money put into it,
and so now it's moving
at full speed now.
And the delivery
thing, we're going
to have to raise
money, billions,
but you're talking about saving
lives for less than $2,000
invested that is funding
vaccination it saves
lives for less than $2,000.
And because in the US we'll
spend $2 million or $20 million
to save a life,
then you say, okay,
are these lives really less
than 1,000 times as valuable?
I mean, maybe there
are 400 as valuable,
but 1,000, that's
getting kind of extreme.
I mean, even in
the Constitution,
slaves were worth what?
3/5 of the vote or
something like that.
So in terms of
discrimination, numerically,
this is pretty extreme stuff if
you fail to fund the vaccines,
which right now, in
the budget crisis,
we're having challenges with
that, but in the long run,
we won't.
On cold chain, there's
this great science
of these super thermoses
that should avoid us having
to use electrification, which
is very tough because if it goes
out, the vaccines spoils,
and electricity policies
in these countries are so bad
that using a solution that's
passive energy to get the
cold basically ice in a super
or in a Dewar's
type thing, we think
we can replace cold chain.
But even if we have to use
refrigerators, we can do it.
You have to over buy the
vaccines because of the fact
that some of the
most will spoil.
So that one is science limited.
The education one, even
though we don't know--
it's mind blowing
how little we know
about what good
teachers do and how
you would invest in
spreading that around, I
think that will finally get
some good work going on.
The field needs about 50 times
as many people working on it,
we need the schools of education
to show up and get serious
about this.
We need some of
the methodologies
of real measurement
to be applied to it.
The hardest thing there,
even once we know what to do,
is going to be convincing
people to do it.
In fact, we have
an existence proof.
Kipp is a charter
school that there's
82 of these schools that
runs for less than the cost
of public schools, and is
able to take inner city
kids, the poorest kids,
and get over 95% of them
to go to college and
get a four year degree,
and it doesn't take numbers.
If you walk into
a Kipp school, you
know you're in a
very different place.
Within 15 minutes
of being in there,
they have some amazing
teaching being done there,
and it's a different personnel
system, it's a long school day,
it's just very different
than a public school.
So here, the limiting
factor absolutely
is taking current
practice, which
is a I'm doing God's
work, don't measure me.
Seniority is good
stuff type system
that there are many great
practitioners in that system,
but there's no real
effort to spread that.
We have five sites in the US
that we've given $400 million
to where the union
and the district
signed up to have
teacher measurement.
So we put webcams in so
you can see the video,
you don't have people
walking into the classroom,
it's very disruptive.
We do teach students
surveys, we do peer surveys,
we look at the test data
coming in and going out
a variety of measures
that we were going
to try to get a consensus.
Four years from now,
that in these five sites
a teachers can say,
hey, I like this.
They got rid of
the right people,
it helped the rest
of us here do better.
It was not capricious,
it was not high overhead,
and I really like this.
If that can happen
in the five sites,
and they can tell everybody
else, that would be good.
If you say, what's the riskiest
thing the foundation is doing?
It's that teacher
personnel's activity
because the status quo is
immensely powerful there.
When we invent vaccines, no
group, I won't name who it is,
can uninvent the vaccine.
If you do good
education, there are
groups that can send
you back to square zero,
and that has happened
in many cases.
DENMON: Hello.
My name's Matt Denmon, and I'm
a PhD in Nuclear Engineering,
and I was wondering, you
mentioned the importance
of low carbon energy
to the world's future.
Can you take a couple
of minutes to talk
about the role of nuclear power
to provide that energy given
that you're investing in
nuclear reactor designs
at third tier power.
GATES: Well, energy
problems, one
of these incredible problems
and the progress of civilization
you can almost measure it as is
the price of energy goes down,
so many great things happen.
We have a civilization that's
based on very cheap power,
and it's great, we
need to continue that.
If you look at what
technologies could really
provide the electricity
demand, say, 40 years from now,
there are very few.
And most the ones that are
kind of cute and cuddly
have two big problems.
I'm talking about solar PB,
solar thermal, solar chemical,
the very solar approaches,
or the wind approach.
Those two have one, it's energy
farming, and so the density,
the acreage involved, the
watts per square meter
of those things, it
makes it very hard.
And when you do farming,
you get wind, you get snow,
you get your capital
equipment isn't
in a coal plant that's
protected from the elements,
it's large, widespread.
So that's very hard,
but even if you
get passed that, there's the
intermittency problem, where
you can't on a 24-hour period,
or when the clouds screw you up
or the wind doesn't blow, you
have this storage problem.
And you can ask--
I think-- reasonable
researchers,
will there be in
the next 40 years
the ability to store,
say, the amount of energy
that the US uses over
a 24-hour period in,
pick your favorite technique.
Battery, water storage,
thermal storage,
there aren't many choices,
and it's not clear.
We should work on that.
Professor Sataway,
a lot of people
are looking at radical
battery technology that
could, in terms of
cost and capacity,
get us in a very
different space than even
the lifting and learning
curve will get us to.
So you don't want to just bet
on those because the costs are
hard, because it's farming,
and the intermittency thing.
Once you get above say, 20%
from intermittent sources,
you've got a problem.
It's cute, it works
well up to about 20%
where you ask the baseload
guys, which today those
are the hydro coal, natural
gas, nuclear guys, you
ask them to suck it up
when the wind doesn't blow.
Anyway, nuclear, in some
ways, is the coolest of all
because you put the
plant near the demand,
and you don't care if
there's sun or not.
There's lots of countries that
don't have sun and wind much
at all, and so you
have to say, are
they willing to have the
political risk of having
their energy coming
from, say, Libya
and over some big
transmission infrastructure.
Anyway, nuclear
has the advantage
that the amount
of energy per atom
is about a million times better
than coal or natural gas.
You start with this
huge advantage,
and yet given the complexity
of the plants and the things
you have to do, you
more than wipe out
your million for one advantage,
and today's nuclear plants
are fairly expensive.
At least the way they're
built outside of China
they're quite expensive.
China is actually building
them in three years
and competitive with
coal, so they're
pushing the state of the art,
and they're standardizing
designs and things like that.
Anyway, so nuclear is
one of the directions
that we should innovate in.
Nuclear innovation
stopped in the 1970s,
we basically have
this sub design thing
that was put into shipping port
for the first power generator,
and we basically
built 400 of those
that are all custom, but
not many interesting way.
They're all LWRs and PWRs.
And the industry did not
innovate much at all.
There's this third generation
passive safety P 1000,
but except for that,
it didn't do much.
The question is, can we
get 1,000 bright minds
with 20 different ideas and
we're starting to see that.
I don't happen to believe
in modular reactors,
but some people do.
That's great.
Some people like these
molten salt reactors,
that's a little bit tricky.
The crazy group I'm backing,
we use U238, depleted uranium.
And because we
have fast neutrons,
we have this neutron budget
that's very different.
Now, our main problem is a
material science problem.
Is these damn neutrons
degrading, the cladding
and everything, and we
don't have a predictable way
of saying, over a 40-year
lifetime, how various materials
deal with that.
If you look at the
fusion guys, they're
neutrons are 1,000 times
worse than our neutrons,
but even ours or are--
those guys have 14 NPV
neutrons, good luck to them.
But some people
should work on that.
That is not an easy thing,
in terms of the economics.
So nuclear, in terms of
[INAUDIBLE] is incredible,
and if you use this approach
we're talking about,
it is infinite, that is you
can filter out of the sea
very cheaply enough, uranium
to run this thing for as long
as the sun will shine.
So in that sense, is it
quote, "renewable" quote,
well it's infinite.
You don't worry about
the amount of uranium.
So anyway, I think it's
one of the approaches that
a ton more should be done in.
We need more money
in material science,
we need more money in
batteries, we need more money
in transmission, this is
an underinvestment area
where if the government
actually does
raise trading money
or carbon tax money.
Some of the bills that
have been proposed,
don't actually fund R&D
at a reasonable level,
so it's a tragic
thing that, hopefully,
if we get a revenue source, that
we can take the energy, R&D,
and get it up maybe a factor
of three or four more.
There's a few good things
going on like [INAUDIBLE],,
but that doesn't
work for nuclear.
But I love I love nuclear.
It does this radiation
thing that's tricky, but--
[LAUGHTER]
--they're good solutions.
It was interesting,
recently in Connecticut,
this natural gas
plant blew up 11 guys.
Just blew them up, actually,
I think killed 506.
If that had been a
nuclear plant everybody
would know about that.
Coal mines, yeah, China
did a good job last year,
they went from 3,300 guys
dying in coal mining accidents,
to 2,600.
Very impressive,
don't you think?
But if nuclear had killed
those 2,600 people,
I mean, we would just be--
kiss the whole industry goodbye.
It's interesting,
deaths per megawatt,
nuclear is the minimizer--
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
--these things, but it's
got a lot of challenges.
But it's great.
I'm glad there's this
Renaissance of people
going into it.
We have this company, and
everybody in the company
is either over 60 because
they have done something,
or they're in their 20s
or 30s because they're
open minded and optimistic.
So it's an interesting
bimodal, we
don't have anybody
in the 40s and 50s,
because that was the
nuclear shut down period
is when those people would
have would have been trained.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a freshman, and I'm
researching with Professor
Sataway, actually.
And thank you for coming
to MIT, though you probably
like Harvard better.
GATES: No, no, no.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Just kidding.
So my question is two part.
The first part is
that earlier you
were talking about how you
think that it'll be a challenge
to get a lot of young people
into researching for helping
poverty and helping the world
issues because they might not
find a financial
incentive in this,
and you said that this would
be an interesting drama
to look at.
But I was wondering,
first of all,
if you could elaborate a little
bit on how you would look
at this problem and
what sorts of approaches
you would take, and do you want
me to say the second part now
or after your answer?
GATES: Oh, I'll
answer this, then
you can do the second part.
Part of the solution is to
take corporations, like drug
companies, phone
companies, banks,
and get them to put
some of their innovators
on these problems that are
less renumeration of perhaps,
but overall, in terms of
their reputation and hiring
and things like that,
and that's happening.
We funded a group called
access to medicines
that ranks the
pharmaceutical companies,
according to how much they
work on diseases of the poor,
and it came out like we thought
it would with GSK on top
and various other
people in the bottom.
And the right thing
happened, which
is the people on the bottom
called this up and said,
this is embarrassing.
Well, are there projects and
things we should be doing?
So spreading that to other
end industries, banking,
cell phones, the food
companies, been great.
We haven't done the index yet,
but the Nestle's, Unilever's,
Coke's, their
willingness to work
with us on agricultural
sourcing, nutrition products.
They've been
amazingly effective.
So bringing the
companies in so that you
have people working at the
companies who can do the stats
is important.
Government funding for
these things, which
is mostly the delivery piece.
That's the foreign
aid budget, making
the case for that, that
that should stay strong,
it's very important.
Getting people
like the NIH, who--
or others, but NIH is big--
to tilt a little bit towards
the disease of the poor
in terms of work they do.
And Francis Collins,
the current director,
is thinking about some creative
things there that'll happen.
Ironically, drug
approval is still
this weird thing where
poor countries don't
trust themselves
to approve drugs,
and so when we want
to do a new TV drug,
it has to be approved--
no country will accept it
unless either FDA, the US
regulator, or EMA, the
European regulator accepts it.
And they don't have
the right process
for triple drug therapy.
They'd make us,
under normal things,
go through three
phase 3s, which that's
15 years and over $1 billion.
So they're working with
us on these things.
We're trying to
get vouchers, where
if you do drugs for the
poor, you get faster FDA
review on your rich world
drugs, so we need government,
philanthropy, and corporate
money to go into this,
and that's the economic piece.
Then, we need the
visibility, where
people feel like this
is a great thing,
and there is
progress, whether it's
prizes or awards or
things like that,
there's a lot more
that can be done.
So what's the second one?
AUDIENCE: The second
is less academic.
I'm just curious, how does being
the richest person in the world
affect your life?
I mean--
[LAUGHTER]
GATES: Well, the marginal
return for extra dollars
does drop off.
I haven't found any burgers at
any price that are better than
McDonald's.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
There's a few things like
air travel, where it's nice--
[LAUGHTER]
But other than that,
overwhelmingly,
once you get past,
some point, I don't
know what it is, a few
million or something,
then it's all about how
you're going to give it back.
Are you going to
pick someone, are
you going to get
involved yourself,
how are you going to do that?
And for some people,
strangely, that's
actually a burden,
where they're worried
they won't to do it well,
or all that, and so partly,
making that easier, making
that more widespread
is one of the things I think is
interesting that can help more.
If we could double philanthropy,
if we could get India and China
billionaires, for example, to
be as generous as the US is
or get us to be
twice as generous
and then get them
to match up to that,
it'd be a substantial
amount of money.
I guess I've used up all
my time, so thank you.
Those were great questions.
Let me just leave you with a
small challenge or opportunity,
which is that on the
Foundation Facebook website,
if you have ideas about
a particular problem
or the general issue
of drawing people in,
if you have ideas
about that, I encourage
you to post there because
I'll go look at that
and see if there's things
that we ought to help promote.
And hopefully, we'll
get a lot of good ideas.
Obviously, coming
here, you are people
who believe in these things, so
I want to thank you for that,
but think hard about how we can
get even more people involved.
[APPLAUSE]
SCHANER: So thank
you, Mr. Gates,
for taking the time to
answer our questions.
Please accept on behalf
of my fellow students,
our appreciation for your
interest in our work,
and I speak for everyone
here in thanking you
for the support and friendship
you've shown to MIT.
[APPLAUSE]